[Music]  our group of friends have known each  other since we were babies  we have trust  in history we own this school  [Music]  who waits for the light she's not from  here  hey how would you like to come hang with  us tonight  too many joy rides and daddy's jaguar  too many white lies  rich kids with nothing but loose ends  super rich kids with nothing but fake  friends  she is a stranger who has found herself  in your friend group with your boyfriend  i promised i would stay away from any  drama  [Music]  did you miss me i know i've missed you  gossip girl an anonymous instagram  account that spies on our students  this just in there's a big secret  amongst the ruling class at constance  miller  why does gossip grow up to get us i'm  not just known  i'm influential and i can't have that  taken away from me  privilege and power will always win in  the end  [Music]  in the best way  [Music]  you